Elon Musk wants to buy Twitter he
announced earlier this week that he's
offering 43 billion dollars to the
Twitter board to buy out all the other
shareholders he wants to buy the entire
company 100 of it and take them private
he already owns just over nine percent
of the business today he wants to
acquire the remaining 91 he thinks that
he needs to make necessary changes when
it comes to preserving the principles of
free speech and he's not able to do that
with the current structure of him as a
minority owner on the board Etc so
here's what he said literally just OG
Elon tweet right here I made an offer
and then attached the uh the SEC
registration uh and if you actually go
through that registration he made some
incredible points that we went through
yesterday but look at this the Tweet got
865 000 likes that that thing's gonna
hit a million for sure and then he came
out and he said uh I want to keep as
many shareholders in a private Twitter
as Allowed by law your boy did some
research 2 000 jobs act it changed used
to be a few hundred were shareholders in
a private business were allowed now it's
2 000. so Elon if he is able to buy the
business and take them private he'll be
able to keep about 2 000 shareholders uh
in the private Twitter he said at the
Ted Talk yesterday he said this isn't
about money he wants to do this to
preserve freedom of speech he thinks
it's extremely important he believes
Twitter is the town hall the internet
and he thinks that they are uh ruining
it potentially by censoring people or
regulating it and not making the code
open source he wants everyone to know
exactly what the algorithm contains
exactly how it is used Etc and you can
build things on top of it secondly he
said he wants to get rid of spam and
Bots the crypto Bots he said are the
most annoying thing in the world he
doesn't want them replying to his tweets
he doesn't want any more fake accounts
he wants to neg he wants to kick them
off the platform he's done with them he
said uh see you later that's going to be
priority number two after preserving
free speech and then he said this isn't
about economics for him he doesn't want
to make money he doesn't care about the
money at all he submitted a bid of uh 43
billion dollars he thinks that is a fair
price for them given their current share
price and we saw yesterday what Goldman
was doing Goldman uh has a sell rating
on the business right now and says that
the stock price is valued at about
thirty dollars and then Twitter hired
the board or hired Goldman to advise the
board on whether that launch price was a
good price or not so we'll see early
reports have said that Twitter's board
is not on board with this of course I
think that's to be expected to some
degree Elon did say that he has a plan B
I don't know what that is he didn't
reveal exactly what that is but we did
have a tweet from Mark Cuban yesterday
uh that had a little bit of a theory
about why Elon Musk might be doing this
Mark Cuban said my conclusion at Elon
Musk is [ __ ] with the SEC his filing
with the SEC allows him to say he wants
to take a company private for 54.20 420.
get it first him I am considering taking
Tesla private at 420 funding secured
price goes up his shares get sold profit
SEC like what the [ __ ] just happened I
mean now that's an all-time tweet and I
think it's fair because a lot of people
are saying that on the internet they're
saying that Elon Musk doesn't actually
care he just wants to [ __ ] around with
people this is fun for him it's a game
he knows that it's nearly impossible to
actually pull this off he would have to
maybe up his bid he has to bring in
outside financing it's going to be
extremely difficult to actually acquire
all the shares some people are not going
to want to do this the boy board is
obviously already against him at this
point when when they told him not to
join the Border he said he's not going
to join the board so this is a nice
Theory from from Mark Cuban but I don't
necessarily believe it I don't know I
don't necessarily believe it I watched
his Ted Talk yesterday uh in Vancouver
and it was interesting to me like he
said this multiple times now he's
obviously a proponent of free speech I
think he understands how important
preserving the principles of free speech
are on the internet and at the end of
the day when you think about it he's
currently up on his investment like 400
million dollars 500 million someone can
do the math but he's up four or 500
million dollars somewhere around there
but not a billion dollars not two
billion dollars not five billion dollars
not seven billion and the guy's worth
nearly 300 billion dollars this is like
point one percent of his total net worth
he would he would gain by doing this
again a lot of money 400 million 500 I
don't care who you are it's a lot of
money but at the end of the day I do not
believe that he's doing this for money
the risk reward scenario in my mind just
doesn't make any sense right if you're
Elon Musk and you're worth 300 billion
dollars why would you go do all this and
potentially potentially right I don't
know exactly what could happen but
potentially you could see problem
surfacing uh with the SEC maybe he
doesn't file something like we saw
earlier last week maybe he doesn't do
something in the right way maybe he does
something wrong the SEC comes after him
gives him a harder time makes life more
difficult for him it's just not worth it
he made bookshares for a pop and he may
eventually sell him but I don't think
this whole move is is being drawn up to
make a profit if that makes sense what
do you think John I don't know if it is
not ethical or not lawful for you to
basically make a bid for a company that
you have no
um desire to buy just to have the price
of the stock go up I'm not really sure
where that falls on that line some
people probably have different views on
the ethical side of things but like how
much money is this really if elon's
buying Twitter this is the equivalent of
if you are worth one million dollars you
went and bought a brand new G-Wagon for
like 150 Grand it's a lot of his net
worth and I'm sure it's uh important to
him that he's losing that much monetary
value or not losing but buying something
else but yeah I don't see I'm doing this
for money at all even though it is that
big chunk of his net worth
um I think he's doing this to preserve
for your speech and to fix Twitter I
think he sees Twitter as that hey you
have 200 million users you've been
slowing over the last few years on user
growth how can we use this platform that
already has a massive reach and isn't
controlled by Zuckerberg and Facebook
and stuff which is obviously a bigger uh
platform but it's also a lot more
expensive right
um frankly out of his range probably to
buy oh well it is out of his range to
buy but look I think he's just doing it
to preserve free speech and the bot
thing is cool because if I'm annoyed
with Bots as a normal human being on
Twitter Elon has to be sick of these
Bots commenting on every single tweet he
has when he's getting a million likes on
tweet I'm sure his flown his phone just
blows up hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time